[Music]
these are some of the most expensive
paintings ever sold at auction with one
thing in common none of the painters are
American but that all changed on
Thursday when this painting by
jean-michel basquiat sold for 110 point
five million dollars tony Jacobo has the
incredible story of the painting and the
man who created it the untitled piece
from 1982 is the work of a 21 year old
artist whose paintings just two years
earlier had been selling for less than
$100 it's now the first painting by an
American to sell at auction for more
than 100 million that's a lot of money
for anything it's a heck of a lot of
money for a painting Jerry Saltz is the
senior art critic for New York magazine
in this skull you see a head in profile
and staring directly at you you get the
sense of a mind burning itself up right
in front of your eyes the winning bid
came from a Japanese billionaire who
announced the purchase on Instagram for
years boskie his paintings have been
selling for tens of millions of dollars
[Music]
serving as my muses jay-z a fellow
Brooklyn native has frequently rapped
about Basquiat and reportedly purchased
the painting Mecca for 4.5 million in
2013 I used to see him on the streets of
New York walking or bicycling around
there was a light that glowed around
Basquiat jean-michel Basquiat died of a
drug overdose in 1988 he was just 27 his
life may have ended early but his place
amongst the greatest artists in history
seems destined outlast us all having an
african-american artist entered the
Pantheon van Gogh Francis Bacon and yes
even Picasso it's about time for CBS
this morning Saturday tonita copal New
York